ce soir dans égale m6 découvrez comment
la réalité peut parfois trompé nos yeux
les magiciens sont capables de faire
apparaître ou disparaître des objets de
couper votre bras en deux morceaux mais
comment font-ils pourquoi notre cerveau
et ils trompés pour le savoir vous
verrez comment en quelques minutes mac
lesggy se fait voler tout le contenu de
ses poches et même sa cravate sans même
s'en rendre compte certains animaux ont
la faculté incroyable de se fondre dans
la nature
à quoi servent les rayures des zèbres et
des tigres comment certains insectes
font-ils pour prendre l'apparence de
branches d'arbres pourquoi le caméléon
change-t-il de couleur en l'espace de
quelques secondes découvrez comment les
scientifiques s'inspire de ces animaux
pour réaliser des tenues de camouflage
et ultra performante il y a quelques
semaines une photo d'une petite robe
faisait le buzz sur internet certains la
voyaient blanche d'autres bleus ou
encore noir e égal m6 a percé le secret
une image qui s'anime alors qu'en
réalité elle fx c'est une illusion
d'optique mais comment parvient elle à
tromper notre cerveau enquête
frédéric et magicien il sait faire voler
les billets mais sa spécialité c'est
plutôt de les dérober dans les poches de
ses spectateurs
aujourd'hui mac lesggy le met au défi
portefeuille qui montre téléphone
cravate frédéric réussira-t-il à lui
prendre tous ces objets
bonjour bonjour mac frédéric vous êtes
magiciens et pickpockets sessa ti paille
que vous pouvez voler à peu près
n'importe quoi à n'importe qui sauf que
moi je suis sur mes gardes et c'est mon
travail de vous lever de votre garde et
on va essayer tout de suite avec un
petit test oui un petit test d'avant je
vais regarder à l'intérieur de cette
poche ici je pense que c'est le
portefeuille qu'on le reste à
l'intérieur de la gauche dans cette
poche ici vous n'avez rien de laurens
alors on laisse on laisse ce la petite
poche ville d'issia comme ça on va
continuer ici un téléphone oui à cette
poche une ceinture mais on la laisse ne
vous inquiétez pas mac vous souvenez
dans quelle poche vous aviez mis le
portefeuille oui ici sinon il est là
c'est la première fois l'an pour leur
poser à l'intérieur de la poche laissez
moi faire c'est mon travail et et s'est
terminée mc comb voilà je vais vous
pouvez vous non à la montre la retraite
ici vous inquiétez pas la montre je ne
la veulent pas aller trop compliqué en
connaît déjà la ceinture mais ça permet
de faire le porte n'était pas les
lunettes voilà on avait aussi le
téléphone parfait nous avions aussi les
lunettes magazine est voilà et pour
terminer la montre la montre que vous
pouvez pour éviter de vous la faire
voler mètres à l'intérieur de la poche
vous la mettez à l'intérieur de la poche
de la veste dans celle-ci voilà cas
comme ça comme ça vous êtes sûr de ne
jamais vous faire piquer ok la montre a
cessé c'est un truc de très simple quand
vous êtes dans le métro à c'est
impossible bah merci beaucoup mac
badagry je me souviens que en émission
vous portiez toujours une cravate
toujours j'adore parce que c'est la
classe mais aujourd'hui il faut la
garder
merci beaucoup mac fabrique bravo merci
c'est incroyable en moins de deux
minutes il lui a tout pris et mac ne
s'est rendu compte de rien même sa
cravate a disparu
mais comment est-ce possible
nous avons demandé à un spécialiste de
la perception kevin au régal de nous
décrypter les méthodes de frédéric
première technique le portefeuille
donc on voit comment le magicien
tir l'attention de mac d'abord sur son
portefeuille et après ils dévient la
tension ou mac sur son autre poche et
pour dévier l'attention de mac en plus
de lui parler le magicien oriente son
regard le magicien que manipuler le
regard de son sujet là en regardant lui
même à faire un endroit ne pas pouvoir
s'empêcher de regarder au même endroit
que quelqu'un on appelle ça la tension
exogènes et c'est ce réflexe
incontrôlable de notre cerveau que
frédéric utilisent pour manipuler mac
mais ce n'est pas tout regardez comment
il lui vole sa montre il tient la montre
ils pressent sur la montre ce qui fait
que max va sentir une pression sur son
poignet et la peau à cette
caractéristique que quand on presse
pendant un moment et reste à une forte
sensation persistante un peu là encore
frédéric utilise une propriété de notre
corps pour nous tromper la persistance
de la sensation du toucher une illusion
sensorielle qui nous trompent pendant
quelques secondes un temps suffisant
pour nous dérober la montre mais le plus
incroyable c'est qu'il réussit à voler
la cravate de mac il a tourné autour de
mac ce qui a fait un grand mouvement et
donc son attention var at elle le fait
tous un but relève la cravate vous
l'aurez compris frédéric manipule notre
attention
mais comment est-ce possible
lorsque nous nous concentrons sur
quelque chose comme par exemple chercher
où est notre portefeuille dans notre
tête une seule et même jaune traite
toutes les informations et se charge
d'organiser notre pensée
c'est le lobe frontal située à l'avant
de notre cerveau
ces airs supérieurs du cerveau ils ont
une capacité de traitement d'information
limités et donc ils peuvent pas traiter
toutes les informations en même temps
autrement dit notre cerveau peine à se
concentrer sur deux choses en même temps
nous avons tenté une petite expérience
nous avons projeté une vidéo à ses
enfants avec une consigne simple compter
le nombre de rebond de la balle rose
vrai c'est parti
alors combien de rebond il comptait
60 53 57 secondes je peux réussir en
réalité le résultat n'a pas vraiment
d'importance mais ont-ils remarqué
quelque chose d'étrange sur cette vidéo
j'ai regardé tarte ou non
vous non plus pourtant un homme déguisé
en cochon rose a traversé l'image
regarder
mais
aucun de ces enfants n'a remarqué le
cochon alors qu'il était pourtant sous
leurs yeux ce phénomène où on voit pas
ce qu'on a on est en train de regarder
ça s'appelle la fait citer in
intentionnel vous vous êtes en train de
faire attention à quelque chose et ce
qui fait que les autres choses dans le
champ visuel tombe à côté ils ne sont
pas perçus en magie tout est bon pour
détourner notre attention mais vous
allez voir que pour nous étonner les
illusionnistes cède aussi de dispositif
mécanique extrêmement ingénieux
lionel est l'un des rois de la grande
illusion sur scène il élabore des
numéros époustouflants
avec l'aide de ses assistantes et de
machines sophistiquées et cette fois ci
c'est mac lesggy qui va jouer le rôle de
l'assistant ceci ressemble étrangement à
une ba on dira plus de guillotine et
bien c'en est une
et pour vous prouver que cette
guillotine fonctionne vraiment lionel
nous fait une démonstration avec des
carottes ôtez le plus important là la
une la blatte embellie pied et bien
cette lame coupe
parfaitement impressionnant attendait
quelqu'un va mettre sa tête là c'est pas
quelqu'un sait vous
maquille va-t-il subir le même sort que
cette carotte suspect nière de l'autre
côté
maintenant vous êtes bien entouré donc
nous allons prendre maintenant la lame
vous la santé oui oui vous êtes prêts
nous on y va 1 2 3
[Musique]
maintenant il faut je remonte la dame
est souvent quand je commente la lame la
tête elle tombe vous l'aimez des deux
dernières fois bien sûr faut tenir bien
le panier sous le coup comme ça ok voilà
maintenant je reprends la lame vous
pouvez poser de talent et il tombait à
beaucoup mieux bon alors c'est quoi le
truc pour que ma tête se retrouver comme
ça pour lober par des lames coupante à
aller lionel
bon j'ai pas dévoiler le truc mais je
voulais aussi procéder pour arriver au
résultat final et oui une lame peut en
cacher une autre
cette fausse guillotine est en réalité
un véritable chef-d'oeuvre de sciences
et de techniques mécanismes cachés
trompe l'oeil tout a été pensé pour que
l'illusion soit parfaite
mais c'est secret doivent rester top
secret
pourtant vous allez voir que pour faire
de la grande illusion on n'a pas
forcément besoin de matériel avec
seulement deux bouts de carton vous
pourrez et tenez votre famille chez vous
ici un simple détournement d'attention
va suffire le carton vous voyez un
premier ici qu'on replace et la voilà là
c'est parfait ensuite on va en prendre
un autre ici
que vous allez placé de l'autre côté et
comme tout bon magicien je fais faire
apparaître d'abord le lapin lapin
et après le lapin ont fait apparaître le
canard bravo et comme je suis un papa
magicien je fais apparaître mon fils
comme or
l'astuce c'est tout simplement d'avoir
un complice déjà présents qui se
faufilent d'un quart temps à l'autre
bluffant non
j'ai beaucoup appris lionel merci
beaucoup merci tom merci à toi je vais
le refaire chez moi avec mes enfants à
la nation à bientôt la voir
détournement d'attention mise en scène
objets truqués vous connaissez
maintenant les rudiments de la magie
certains animaux ont la faculté
incroyable de se rendre invisible dans
la nature
savez vous que les rayures des tigres et
des zèbres sont en fait des camouflages
indispensables à leur survie comment des
insectes arrive-t-il à se confondre avec
des branches pourquoi le caméléon
change-t-il de couleurs et comment des
spécialistes s'inspire de ces animaux
pour inventer des tenues de camouflage
étonnante
bienvenue dans le parc animalier de
thoiry parmi tous les animaux qu'on peut
admirer certains ont un atout
particulier le camouflage démonstration
ici dans large des petites bêtes ça ce
projet en tulle et cherche on me renvoie
à nos manches courtes ou souffrent avec
les feuilles et vous que voyez-vous
un deux trois quatre voici les phasmes
ces insectes sont de véritables
champions du camouflage pour se rendre
invisible il se déguise à la perfection
en branches ou en feuilles
mais à quoi sert le camouflage le
camouflage quand on est une proie ça
sert à se dissimuler pour ne pas être
mangé et quand on est un prédateur ça
vus par la proie et pour mieux la
surprendre pour mieux l'attraper et vous
allez voir que cet incroyable mimétisme
ne date pas d'hier donc l'adaptation des
phasmes à leur environnement
voilà
en fait cette cette adaptation à
l'environnement a été acquise au cours
de milliers de millions d'années même
différentes mutations au fil du temps et
est sélectionné dans la mesure où elle
permettait à l'espèce de survivre encore
mieux vous l'avez vu certains animaux
copie leur environnement pour se
camoufler mais d'autres ont des motifs
sur leur pelage tout aussi efficace pour
disparaître les rayures du tigre par
exemple sont en fait un parfait trompe
l'oeil
critique est rayé c'est le seul fait la
rayer alternance de raynouard et sur un
pelage fauve il faut imaginer dans une
végétation dense avec les la lumière et
le jeu d'ombré de lumière et bien le tic
à sa silhouette qui est complètement
cassé et qui permet du coup de passer
complètement inaperçue surtout si les
mobiles pour pouvoir rattraper sa croix
si en terrain dégagé le tigre est bien
visible ses rayures sont bien adaptés
aux forêts tropicales de son habitat
naturel et en 2010 des scientifiques
anglais ont confirmé que les félins qui
vivent dans une végétation dense comme
les tigres ou cette panthère ont des
motifs complexes tandis que ceux qui
vivent à découvert dans les savanes où
les prairies comme le lion ont des
plages uniforme une des proies les plus
appréciés du lion c'est le zèbre mais
pourquoi celui-ci at-il des rayures
alors qu'il vit dans une savane dégagé
et bien c'est un camouflage efficace
lorsque le zèbre et dans son troupeau
quand le troupeau est en mouvement il y
aurait une création d'un d'une illusion
d'optique qui fait que le prédateur
pourrait avoir des problèmes pour
identifier le sens de progression du
troupeau et la vitesse de progression
par l'ensemble des rayures qui
bougeraient tout en même temps
l'effet de masse créer une illusion
d'optique conséquence les prédateurs ont
plus de mal à percevoir les déplacements
et les formes de ces animaux c'est
exactement comme cette spirale
lorsqu'elle tourne sur elle même nous
avons l'impression que les bandes
s'écarte vers l'extérieur
regardez ces bateaux ses rayures ne sont
pas l'oeuvre d'un peintre illuminé mais
les camouflages de la marine anglaise
pendant la première guerre mondiale pour
tromper les canonniers ennemis comme
pour le zèbre l'évaluation de la forme
de la trajectoire du bateau étaient
perturbés par ces rayures
et depuis l'homme n'a pas cessé de
perfectionner ses techniques de
camouflage aujourd'hui pour approcher au
plus près les animaux sans se faire
repérer il existe des tenues très
innovante combien d'hommes voyez vous
ici
1 vous êtes sûr et bien non il y en a
deux et comme vous les animaux aussi n'y
voit que du feu
pourquoi l'animal va percevoir cette
silhouette humaine tout simplement parce
que on a un aplat de beige qui n'existe
pas dans la nature l'animal ne va pas
percevoir cette silhouette parce qu'elle
est tout simplement fracturée ici l'on à
ses branches qui viennent casser la
silhouette humaine comme pour le tigre
les lignes des structures les formes
nous sommes à cestas à 20 km de bordeaux
c'est dans ce bureau d'études que ses
tenues très performantes sont inventés
en plus de casser les formes les
ingénieurs crée des effets de profondeur
ont tout aussi trompeur pour les animaux
pour augmenter encore cette perception
de de profondeur on va rajouter un fonds
qui est beaucoup plus floue ce qui va
créer ses premiers plans ce deuxième
plan et ce plan arrière qui va renforcer
l'aspect réaliste en scène du camouflage
qui va faire un peu l'effet d'un trompe
l'oeil et la personne disparaît
totalement dans le décor et ses
camouflages sont adaptés aux saisons
exactement comme certains animaux
regardez ce renard arctique qui est
blanc les mois d'hiver et devient marron
l'été pour l'homme c'est pareil les
motifs s'adapte aux différentes saisons
printemps été automne hiver et puis
blanc afin de disparaître dans la neige
mais alors qu'est ce donc que cette
tenue étrange orange fluo ou on a deux
contraintes la première contrainte
c'était la sécurité des chasseurs les
chasseurs se voient entre eux et la
deuxième contrainte c'était que l'animal
ne voit pas le chasseur donc on a fait
appel à des scientifiques pour
déterminer quelle était la meilleure
couleur et en fait c'était le orange
fluo et oui les animaux ont une
particularité ils ne voient pas les
mêmes couleurs que nous démonstration
voici la tenue fluo vu par l'homme
impossible de ne pas la voir et voilà ce
que cela donne vue par un chevreuil ou
un sanglier du gris
la perception des couleurs est très
différente entre les humains trust nous
ce qu'on voit et beaucoup d'herbivores
de grands herbivores les goûts à les
cervidés non pas les capteurs pour le
rouge donc tout ce qui est rouge va
paraître comme un peu grisâtre et un peu
terne à part l'homme et les grands
singes les mammifères ne détectent pas
les nuances de rouge car leurs rétines
au fond de l'oeil ne possède pas de
caunes des cellules sensibles aux
teintes rouges c'est pour cela que ce
camouflage orange est efficace mais
certains animaux ont un système encore
plus incroyable que l'homme aimerait
bien reproduire ils sont capables de
changer de couleur en un instant le plus
connu c'est bien sûr le caméléon
[Musique]
mais contrairement à ce que l'on pense
si le caméléon change de couleur ce
n'est pas pour se cacher alors par
exemple si une femelle se trouve en
présence d'un mâle et qu'elle n'est pas
réceptive elle va le signaler en
changeant de couleur donc le message est
très clair pour le mal pas besoin de
s'approcher lé pa dakor
démonstration notre vétérinaire présente
un mal à cette femelle
et en à peine 30 secondes la femelle
change de couleurs et de motifs en clair
elle n'apprécie pas du tout la présence
de cet important mais quel est le secret
du changement de couleur de ces drôles
de reptiles
la variation de coloration chez les
caméléons ta phénomène assez complexe en
fait
qui est liée à l'existence de
différentes couches de cellules dans
l'épaisseur de la peau qui renferme des
piles mans de différentes couleurs sous
sa peau le caméléon possède des cellules
qui contiennent plusieurs traces de
pigments
du jaune du rouge et du brun en
contractant plus ou moins ces cellules
il passe d'une quinte à une autre et
pour compléter sa palette de couleurs
certaines de ces cellules contiennent
aussi de minuscules cristaux qui vont
des composés la lumière
la lumière va venir se réfléchir comme
sur un prisme et on aura différentes
colorations et voilà comment le caméléon
nous offre une explosion de couleurs du
rouge au bleu en passant par le vert
mais il n'est pas le seul animal à
pouvoir changer sa couleur en temps réel
certains animaux marins sont étonnants
regardez bien vous voyez un rocher eh
bien non c'est une pieuvre qui a pris
les couleurs de la roche hélas et
calamars ils sont capables de changer de
teinte comme par magie
rayures tarrach couleurs la nature a
doté les animaux de camouflage très
élaborés que les scientifiques étudient
de près et peut-être que dans un futur
proche l'homme parviendra à reproduire
un camouflage transparent comme ces
méduses
souvenez-vous il ya quelques mois la
couleur de cette petite robe faisait le
buzz sur internet et elle blanche ou
bleue impossible de mettre les
internautes d'accord et ce n'est pas la
seule illusion d'optique une illusion
visuel qui a de quoi nous rendre fou
comment ces illusions joue-t-elle détour
à notre cerveau qui les fabriquent et à
quoi peuvent bien servir
réponse
il y a trois mois la starlette kim
kardashian pose et une étrange question
sur les réseaux sociaux de quelle
couleur est cette robe je la vois
blanches et dorées kenny la voix noire
et bleue qui a un problème de vue
voilà comment une simple question a
déclenché une gigantesque polémique aux
quatre coins du monde mais alors de
quelle couleur est elle vraiment nous
avons percé le mystère cette célèbre
robe la voici
et oui elle est bleue thérèse collins et
spécialiste des illusions visuelles pour
comprendre pourquoi nous ne voyons pas
tous cette robe de la même couleur elle
et ses collègues ont décidé d'étudier le
phénomène scientifiquement ils ont
présenté la fameuse photo à des
volontaires en leur demandant d' ajuster
une couleur de la robe jusqu'à ce qu'il
la voit grise en fonction des teintes
ajouter les chercheurs ont pu déterminer
de quelle couleur chaque volontaire voit
vraiment la rogue résultat 35 % d'entre
eux la perçoivent blanches et dorées 26%
la voie bleue et noire le reste hésite
entre les deux couleurs mais comment
est-ce possible
la photo est un peu bizarrement fait
elle est un petit peu sur exposé il ya
beaucoup de lumière à l'arrière mais
elle semble être un petit peu dans
l'ombre le cadrage est très restreint
donc on sait pas très bien comment
interpréter cette scène est donc pour en
fait interpréter cette image on doit
faire certaines suppositions par rapport
à l'éclairage
premier constat en l'absence de contexte
et sans points de repères notre cerveau
peut donc interpréter une photo de
plusieurs manières
les personnes qui interprètent cette
image comme étant une robe blanche ils
supposent que cette lumière bleue qui
sort de l'image et les résultats de
l'éclairage de la scène
les gens qui suppose au qui perçoivent
cette robe comme étant bleu perçoivent
le même bleu que les autres mais
simplement ils l'attribuent à la robe
plutôt qu'à la lumière
dans les deux cas vous n'avez donc aucun
problème de vu si vous voyez la robe
bleue votre cerveau déduit que
l'éclairage est plutôt jaune
si vous voyez la robe blanche c'est que
votre cerveau suppose que l'éclairage
est plutôt bleuté
mais vous allez découvrir que les formes
et les mouvements créés eux aussi des
illusions surprenante direction
l'explorer d'hommes à vitry sur seine et
marne valentine et l'une âgée de 10 à 12
ans vont découvrir les secrets des
illusions d'optique est une des
premières illusions d'optique qui nous
attend c'est dragon me suivent des yeux
non
ils sont creux c'est une illusion
d'optique et c'est notre cerveau qui
fait ça mais pourquoi notre cerveau ne
voit-il pas que les têtes de dragons
sont creuses tous les objets qu'on voit
au quotidien
ils sont comment ils sont creux où on
peut les toucher
on peut les prendre on peut les toucher
donc ils sont en volume en relief donc
notre cerveau quand ils voient un objet
ils se disent c'est en relief comme
d'habitude donc qui s'imaginent que la
tête du dragon les pats d'entre elles et
devant donc il imagine un point devant
qu'il n'existe pas il fabrique une tête
de dragon en relief tous à leurs parents
en clair notre cerveau est habitué à
voir des volumes plutôt que des creux il
interprète donc ces dragons comme étant
en relief alors que ce n'est pas le cas
[Musique]
on enchaîne du coup avec la 2e légion
d'optique prenez quelques secondes et
faites le test vous aussi en déplaçant
votre regard dans cette image
on a l'impression que qui fait quoi
pourtant ce texte est parfaitement fixe
c'est encore un tour dans notre cerveau
wallon il nous fera réfléchir on en a
besoin quand même le secret de cette
illusion ce sont les contours noirs et
blancs qui encadre les lettres sur la
ligne du dessus le noir est à gauche et
le blanc à droite alors que sur la
deuxième ligne celle inverse et ainsi de
suite
l'autre cerveau dibaya du noir à gauche
de partout mais quand on descend annoncé
inverse donc ils obligés de tout changer
et s'adapter à non c'est pas du noir et
du blanc c'est l'opposé alors du coup
l'image on a l'impression qu'elle est
complètement décalé les contrastes
changé on a l'impression que le texte il
bouge tout seul
là encore notre cerveau fait ce qu'il
peut pour s'adapter mais il a du mal si
les illusions nous fascine et nous amuse
elles permettent aux scientifiques de
sonder les mystères de notre cerveau la
plupart du temps ce sont d'ailleurs des
chercheurs qui décret comme jean
laurenceau qui a inventé cette illusion
bluffante
regardez ce carré à bord blanc dont les
coins sont cachés par quatre carrés
bleus il tourne dans le sens des
aiguilles d'une montre mais si on enlève
les caches alors on ne voit plus que des
segments qui se déplacent de manière
anarchique pourtant c'est exactement la
même animation
pour comprendre jean laurens haut à
utiliser un magnétoencéphalographie
il permet d'enregistrer l'activité du
cerveau lorsque nous regardons cette
illusion
on observe une région particulière ce
qu'on appelle le cortex pariétal c'est
cette zone qui va s'activer quand on
perçoit le mouvement cohérent globale du
carré elle va plus active et que
lorsqu'on perçoit un mouvement
incohérent des segments qui composent le
carré lorsque nous cherchons à compléter
mentalement un objet en partie caché ce
serait donc dans le cortex pariétal que
ça se passerait quand les coins du carré
sont masquées il faut bien les
reconstruire d'une façon ou d'une autre
on appelle ça de la complétion de
contour cette complétion de contours et
les nécessaires pour faire en sorte que
les segments appartiennent bien aux
mêmes objets la complétion de contour
c'est ce qu'on fait tous les jours sans
s'en rendre compte
regardez je vais cacher une main avec
l'autre et bien vous allez observer ici
le bout de mes doigts mon poignet et
vous allez bien comprendre malgré le
fait qu'une partie simplement de
l'information est disponible que c'est
bien un objet entier qui est perçu la
découverte de ce mécanisme pourrait
aider à mieux comprendre certaines
lésions du cerveau comme les troubles de
la perception
mais les artistes aussi s'intéresse aux
illusions d'optique ces gigantesques
oeuvre en 3d ont été réalisés par
françois habel années l'un des rares
français à les maîtriser il a fait son
entrée au livre des records avec se
trompe l'oeil de plus de 4000 mètres
carrés à lyon sur la place bellecour il
utilise une méthode bien particulière
pour créer ces trompe-l'oeil
l'anamorphose c'est à dire une
déformation géométriques
j'ai pris deux lampes torches je
projette un cercle ok
eh bien je fais tourner la torche pour
dessiner une anamorphose elle a projeté
elle n'a pas changé cette
cette torche et adultes donnent une
anamorphose d'un cercle et tirer une
forme en hauteur permet une fois au sol
de conserver ses proportions initial
ensuite notre cerveau qui va au plus
facile reconstruit une boule qui est
pour lui une forme familière alors
qu'elle n'existe pas l'illusion est
parfaite
je pars d'un dessin en fait qui est
celui ci et après moi je le les tirs
dans l'espace pour que ce dessin soit vu
de ce point là et qui donne ses effets
de relief autre technique bien connue du
trompe l'oeil les ombres pour créer des
jeux d'ombrés françois incliné les
panneaux en fonction de la trajectoire
du soleil et lorsque des personnes
entrent dans le décor elle semble
changer de taille eh bien on a des
effets que cette personne si je me mets
dans laxe est très grande et l'hôte est
très petit sa femme complètement
loufoque bizarre est ce assez j'adore
vous l'aurez compris la réalité n'est
pas forcément celle que vous croyez de
la recherche scientifique à l'art du
trompe l'oeil les illusions n'ont pas
fini de jouer avec notre cerveau
[Musique]